if you're thinking about it we're
talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
appears Morgan I'm censored tonight some
very sad breaking news as I came on air
Sinead O'Connor the Irish singing Legend
has died aged just 56 and will pay
tribute to her in the program tonight
also tonight A cavalcade a stop Top
Sporting talents follow Ronaldo to Saudi
Arabia now the desert kings are
reportedly ready to spend a billion
euros on Killian mbappe should we be
afraid of the Saudi World takeover or
should we embrace it legendary promoter
Eddie Hearn will be with me live to talk
about that and much more
Hollywood star Kevin Spacey found not
guilty on nine counts of sexual assault
with his reputation in tatters is there
a way back for his Hollywood career
we'll debate that
plus the weird Cult of Putin why are so
many online influencers in love with a
murderous dictator I'll debate that with
one of them live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening for London welcome to Piers
Morgan ascendant uh we start the show
with some very sad breaking news the
Irish music legend Sinead O'Connor has
died at the age of just 56. she was a
troubled and Beautiful Soul Fearless
uncompromising shocking courageous she
was a rebel at heart she took on the
Catholic Church she used a prime time
performance on ustv the stage of protest
even as everyone warned it it could ruin
her career above also she Enchanted
Millions with a song that's known across
the world and across Generations few
people can truly say their voice to find
an era but sinead's dead put simply
nothing compared to Sinead O'Connor
[Music]
nothing compared to you
when a statement tonight the singer's
family said it is the great sadness that
we announced the passing of our beloved
Sinead a family and her friends are
devastated I'm sure that millions of
people across the world will share that
sentiment generally calls led a very
turbulent life she was said her
rebellious streak was driven by the
abuse she suffered as a child and that
music rescued her is certainly Unleashed
to creative talent that made her world
famous she struggled with her mental
health for many years and talked very
openly and powerfully about that and
tragically she lost her 17 year old son
Shane to Suicide just 18 months ago I
had a number of exchanges with Sinead
and interviews over the years they were
most definitely uncensored this was the
last time I interviewed her
Sinead exactly we go back a long way I
used to write about you as a young pop
writer we used to lockhorns Glass blah
blah blah I never doubted your talent I
mean the one thing that Rose above all
the controversies all the stuff was that
you just had this wondrous voice and to
hear you now if anything even richer
your voice I think than it was back then
it's a magical thing to hear I mean at
your heart you're just a great singer
aren't you yeah I think I was very young
I wasn't ready for the type of success
inverted comments that happened you know
what I mean I wasn't really setting out
to be a pop star so I didn't really fit
the mold I was more of a punk
she was and she was a unique talent a
unique character well I'm joined then by
RTE radio presenter from Ireland Dave
Fanning his interview she made multiple
times Dave uh very sad this news it
really gave me a jolt when I read this
just before I came on air you knew
Sinead very well you interviewed her
she's an Irish music legend of course
what is your reaction to this news
tonight
dreadfully sad I mean an Irish Cultural
Legend as much as an Irish music legend
obviously it's the music that people
would know are best by I mean she's got
about 10 Studio albums she must have 30
collaborations with some of the biggest
artists around obviously she took
Prince's song and made it into the
greatest love song of all time there it
is there yeah I mean absolutely no
question about it it's her song her
first two albums just broke every moment
you could imagine the next ones were all
quite kind of experimental sometime the
Chan knows the old Irish singing one
there was a reggae one they didn't
always work but the last two albums that
she made were just a great collections
of new pop songs and they were really
good and with David Holmes the the
Belfast musician she had another one an
11th one coming out I don't know if it
still will I'm not sure but it was the
cultural impact that she had I mean she
was self-deprecating she was pragmatic a
very sharp Observer she was
uncompromising and she had no regrets
about anything at all and she was an
absolute icon to a certain generation of
Irish people and that Generation Now is
anything between the ages of 20 and
maybe 45 or 50. the older generation
they didn't necessarily like all the
things she did tearing up the picture of
the Pope on TV 25 I mean 30 years ago
was obviously something that didn't
necessarily go down well with some
people but how prescient was she
everything she was saying every reason
she did it came true 10 years later with
the Dreadful Dreadful um Revelations of
just exactly how crazy the church was
yeah I mean she was controversial she
was outspoken but she spoke her mind I
always felt that it was sincere you know
I had some great run-ins with her where
she'd tear into me and the next thing
would be drinking Guinness and she'd be
smothering me in kisses and love and she
was like that she was a contrarian
figure I think she liked rattling cages
and she liked telling you what she
really thought of you whether it was
good or bad and so you know I feel very
uh like I say I feel very sad about this
news I also feel it probably I don't
want to guess here but it probably can't
be unconnected to the tragedy about her
son who died only 80 18 months ago of
course taking his own life well I don't
want to be too sad all the time about
something and this is still like just
kind of trying to to put this grief into
some kind of um perspective but in some
ways she was a bit Piers Morgan she was
an Asian provocateur in many ways she
really knew how to Rattle people's cages
and was able to stand up to whatever had
to be said to her in terms of wrong
she'd say no here's why I'm not wrong
and she was fun and she was great she
was very fearless and fragile often at
the same time no regrets she did put
herself in some very very tough
situations and you're kind of used to
wonder and say why is she doing this the
very first interview she did she did
with me on the radio back in 87
direction or whatever it was and then
the last thing she did was on stage in
Dublin there's a thing in Britain called
the Mercury music prize in our we call
it the choice prize and at Vicar Street
in Dublin she came out first time since
Shane had died and I had to give her the
award for her second album like it was a
classic album award thing and I didn't
even think she'd come to collect it and
she did and she came out stage and
smiled and honestly not so much the
standing ovation but the love in the
room I know it's got a cliche so I'll
just leave it at this everybody wants to
put their arms around her she knew that
and smiled all her way home fantastic
Dave thank you so much for joining me
I'm so sorry for your loss for the
country's loss you know she really was
an iconic figure and I thought you
summed her up absolutely perfectly or
they can already hear her ranting about
you saying she was Piers Morgan that
would be just about the last things
you'd want to hear but she'd also have a
wry smile because she uh she and I had a
a Bittersweet but always fun uh
relationship Dave thank you I appreciate
that look take it easy thanks Sinead
O'Connor who's died at the age of just
56. what a what a voice what a talent
what a mark she made
well my next guest is from a sporting
Dynasty despite his father Barry Hearn
claiming his son was born with a silver
spoon Eddie Hearn has grown the family
business signing boxing's first billion
dollar deal become one of the sports
most recognizable faces around the world
including America but just how far will
the promoter go to follow the money
Saudi Arabia's so-called Sports washing
Empire is expanding across football
Formula One Golf and of course boxing
and there's now a reported one billion
dollar offer for Paris saint-germain's
killing mbappe should we be afraid of
the Saudi World takeover well I'm
delighted to say Eddie hurt is joining
me live
uncensored in the studio welcome Eddie
good evening great to see you um
this whole Saudi thing has been
fascinating to me watching Live Gold for
example take on the PGA and basically
batter the PGA into submission watching
Formula One embracing all the money from
the Middle East and then my friend
Cristiano Ronaldo going out to Saudi and
really transforming World football you
look at all the stars going there now
following Ronaldo as he said he could be
the fifth best league in the world
within a year it is extraordinary to
watch
should we be concerned about this what's
your view of this Saudi domination of
World sport I mean we we first went
there in 2019 with Anthony Joshua
against Andy Reeves in the rematch got a
lot of criticism obviously I don't like
to position boxing differently to goal
for tennis but it's prize fighting and
our job is to obviously maximize the
earnings of a fighter over a short
period of time what I've learned through
my work out there is you've got a lot of
passionate people about sport the
political argument of sports washing and
so forth now I don't want to push that
away and say I'm you know that's not my
responsibility I don't see that as much
I see a group of people in charge of
certain sports that are ultimately huge
fans with a unparalleled budget and
people in boxing that have actually
worked amongst the Grassroots is up 300
for boxing clubs I think they've
quadrupled the number of amateur boxing
clubs Etc but it's just people in charge
who have a huge passion for a sport I
was there three or four weeks ago
talking boxing in in you know in in
Prince khalid's house who runs the
boxing they're all watching football
unbelievable uh football fans well
Ronaldo told me that the fans it's
incredible he said the stadiums are
packed out the fans go crazy they're
very knowledgeable the quality of the
football is better than he thought it
was and he's obviously massively
improving with all these signings you've
got all these top players going there's
no doubt they're on a mission to be very
dominant in the sport do you see a
downside to this or when you see in
Batman potentially going for one season
if he accepts this deal for a billion
dollars most people will think this is
completely insane they would see it as a
marketing play yeah I see I think we can
talk about it we can debate it we can
talk about the pros and cons but all of
it's irrelevant it's not going away
right this is a group of very determined
individuals who want to make Saudi
Arabia the Forefront of global Sport and
they have the budget to do it at every
single level and is there a lot of
hypocrisy and the reason I asked that
take someone like Jordan Henderson who's
just gone to play in Saudi I remember at
the Qatar World Cup he said when we were
given the briefing on Qatar which is
really important it was shocking and
disappointing it's horrendous really
when you look at some of the issues
they're currently happening and have
been happening over there all sounds
great right to the point he then gets on
a plane then goes and plays in Saudi
Arabia he's put his morals to one side
and his concerns is there a lot of
hypocrite I believe there is I think
that if you look at most countries
around the world us including you know
we if you go to a Qatar like I didn't
talk to the locals I said what about
your illegal invasion of Iraq who gives
you the right to put a Halo on your
heads
yeah and I think every country has their
problem obviously Saudi Arabia perhaps
more so from a human rights issue but
also sometimes I return to this country
and look at the problems we have here
right and prefer to worry about that I
think when we talk about sport you know
like I said this isn't going away this
is a group of people that are very
determined to make an impact is it good
or bad let's be honest and what I didn't
like about live particularly was the
press conferences that were held yeah
where people were talking and glorifying
the format and the change in you know in
structure moving from the PGA Tour to
lived let's just be completely honest
and by the way I don't blame these
people it's a huge amount of money that
will set them up their kids generations
for years and years Beyond who can
actually blame Ronaldo or mbappe for
taking a deal like that you can
celebrate ones that don't because of
other issues or because of you know a
moral principle but at the end of the
day in all business and sport is
business as well money talks and they're
not going to be able to reject this
amount of money over time why is money
not yet talked Anthony Joshua fighting
Tyson Fury
um I think it's a lot of things I think
Tyson Fury who
I'm saying he's slowly being found out
but he's not always as truthful as he
appears on Instagram timing is is
something I think television rights and
Partnerships are something
um Instagram is something ego is very
much everybody wants to see this
everybody wants to see it and on August
12th Anthony Joshua will fight dillian
white on the Zone after that he will
fight Deontay Wilder in Saudi Arabia and
then after that it has to be Tyson Fury
Tyson Fury turned down the Alexander
usick fight the biggest fight really the
most important fight in boxing the
Undisputed Heavyweight World
Championship two fight an MMA fighter
who's never had a fight before in his
life also in Saudi Arabia we've got to
be honest Tyson Fury cares about one
thing only the money right don't talk to
me about Legacy don't talk to me about
Undisputed don't talk to me about it he
has banned over everybody out there who
what who everybody out there oh Wilder
who are young boys so he's be Klitschko
and Wilder that's his wins he needs to
be usick and AJ and then we can talk
about him as I believe he is as one of
the greatest heavyweights of all time
listen he's unbelievable what he's come
back from incredible couldn't commend
him more but to create a legacy to
create that history to go down as a
modern day great to put yourself up with
Ali with Lennox Lewis with Joe Frazier
those guys he's got to be usick and he's
got to be Anthony Joshua but
particularly usick who's the Undisputed
Champion well I think he will be using
he'll fight him and beat him and then
the real fight I want to see is him and
Joshua everybody let's get through
dillian white first yeah
you because I
I got to know you and your dad we
holiday in the same place and uh I've
seen how competitive you are even at
play golf with each other you were
brought up in a very similar atmosphere
as a family to the one that I've tried
with my kids that my parents drive with
me where it was tough love you know like
No Quarter was given your dad wanted you
to be successful and he felt the best
way to do it was for example you put a
cricket net in your garden a bowl as
fast as he could he's a very good
cricketer and could bald quick when you
were like young kid 11 12 years old then
when you were 16 you'd been boxing for a
few years he said we're gonna have a
fight you and me in the ring and a pair
of you get in a ring and have a proper
match and first of all what happened in
that fight well you know I was a big kid
I mean I'm six foot five now but he
always said to me look you know you have
to understand it and people there was
there was an article in a garden
recently where the writer kind of failed
to understand
my child wasn't normal and as I get
older I realized more and more it
actually wasn't normal but it worked for
us my dad was from dagenham right the
one thing he hated more than anything
growing up was
a sport kid right a rich kid who had
everything and he was petrified that I
was going to be that kid so he drilled
into me work ethic working class
mentality you get given Nothing winning
is everything and I was brought up on
sport you know it was the one thing that
taught me discipline manners respect
winning losing of course physical health
menswear all of that stuff working as a
team and that's why I'm so passionate
about that for the next Generation but
you know he always said to me when you
get to 18 I'm going to take you down a
gym and I'm going to give you a complete
pasting he said you're a soft Silver
Spoon spoiled kid and I'm from dagenham
and I'm gonna you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna take you to school so I said oh I
understand and I boxed a little bit you
know I thought I was good but I was
terrible but I got to 16 and I was
already six foot I was 14 Stone he said
look we need to bring It Forward a
couple of years because he was walking
yeah I was a bit of a lump so we went
down to the Romford boxing gym and there
was Fighters down there we put on these
little gloves and we got in the ring and
the bell went we're doing three two
minute rounds and a bell ring and I'll
never forget because he came at me and
I've never seen such determination and
grit to inflict damage on his own side
yeah and her teeth were great you know
and he was banging away and I was taking
shots and anyway beat me up for the
first round and in the second round he
was completely gone he's out of gas and
I've I've left up to the body took one
knee got up done him again and he was
counting it out and the next day it's in
every paper and he's told he couldn't
have been prouder you know normally if
your son gives you a bit of a posting
you'd sort of want to keep it a bit
quiet he was so proud that and how did
you feel
about the whole thing I knew you know
again he done a job on Me growing up you
know with the right mentality but you
know he was like you're one of us you
know what I mean that's how he felt and
and the problem is is you know sport is
the answer for saying we were talking in
the you know in the green room so sport
is the answer for me totally for the
growth the education and molding I mean
I'm so mental health about the
resilience for all of it boxing in the
community now politicians the government
they don't go to these clubs now if you
go in there and see the types of kids
that are in these clubs and speak to
every fighter that exists and some of
them obviously are a bigger torch than
others Anthony Joshua great example got
in trouble with the police got arrested
stumbled across Finchley ABC didn't go
in there to be heavyweight world
champion went in there for some
direction some hope that family feeling
that a boxing gym gives you you know and
through it actually became Olympic
Champion and World Heavyweight Champion
but every fighter that we represent will
tell you the same story boxing changed
or boxing saved my life that goes across
all sports what do you feel about two
issues about sport right now one that at
school everyone gets a participation
prize even if they come last secondly
boys now race against girls which I
think is completely ridiculous many
schools have gone down this way unisex
sports day which I think is ridiculous
and then you have the the ongoing issue
of transgender athletes in sport
dominating biological females in women's
sport let's take the first one
let's take the last one first the
transgender issue what do you feel about
that as a sports promoter
I mean I'm you know I'm of the old
school mentality where you know of
course male athletes compete against
male athletes female athletes complete
against uh female athletes it's an
awkward conversation to have it's not
about a level plan when you talk about
physical Sports there is no way unboxing
is a great example we haven't had that
problem yet well if Mike Tyson suddenly
turn around I'm now Michelle Tyson and
I'm going to compete as a woman the
world would go completely crazy and say
you're going to kill somebody you're
going to kill a woman but we seemed
perfectly okay with six foot four inch
swimmers my biological males dominating
women
weightlifters bizarre shouldn't be
allowed and ultimately you know whoever
you upset you upset but not sport not
not not a fair sport not a fair race not
a Fair competition it's to me it's the
same as doping you're giving yourself a
physical advancement exactly which of
course can't be allowed kids and
participation prizes at school if you
come some love when I I mean I used to
win the non-finalist race on sports day
which was for all the losers but I used
to make sure I was the best loser
because I wasn't an athlete my two
brothers used to win everything and my
sons have been very good at sports day
but I I wasn't but I remember the pain
of losing and I wanted to be the best
and he's the best loser but this idea
that if you come last you still get a
little prize because they can't be upset
this this mindset is where I think this
country is going so wrong yeah and I'm a
bad person to ask because I couldn't be
more on your side than on your page
winning
this is how I grew up winning is
everything right it's not it's the only
thing that matters whatever you do win
yes and that's the attitude we have in
sport in business doesn't matter if I'm
playing my old man over a game of table
tennis he's diving on the floor you know
it's absolute Do or Die Winning is
Everything I struggle having two
daughters especially and one is very
good at football and she'll get taken
off in matches because we have to give
everybody again
but it's so difficult you know I mean on
one stage we talk about the the
importance of sport yeah and we talk
about encouragement
you can't close the door to a young kid
no but you tell the young kid if you
want to be as good as that kid here's
what you've got to do but at the same
time we we don't want to close don't
sacrifice your principles I will never
and and you know don't let them take
your daughter off my old man referred to
me recently as a project you know and
that that was like that's his thing you
know it's about winning and we have that
mentality what we must do is we must
continue to create winners because if
it's in sport if it's in business in
everything in life and you know
unfortunately now we live in a world
where everybody actually tries to bring
the winners down and deflate the winners
you know make sure they just for this
thing of having a school on sports day
boys competing with girls I think he's a
complete Madness complete Madness what
are you trying to do to these girls kill
their self-esteem tell them they're not
as good as boys simply because the boys
have a physical Advantage I think all of
it is wrong
I think completely wrong and also on the
winning argument ultimately kids need to
be told winning you know I used to come
home from a game of cricket
my old man would go to me how'd you get
on I'll go oh no we've got a good ball
got four useless right what's the matter
with your Gap there tomorrow and go
knocking 100 right right and that was it
that was life you know that to me is
about teaching someone to to Aid to want
to compete properly why bother entering
anything that's competitive if you don't
want to win and why is winning such a
bad thing these days right nowadays
people who lose get celebrated if they
quit they get more celebrated even if
they compete but that's a classic
British trait isn't it we we really do
glorify our greatest losers or almost I
mean Frank Bruno is a great example was
one of the most popular you know
characters Sportsmen in this country won
a world heavyweight title actually
people sort of went ah he's won the
World Heavyweight time yeah it was like
a bit of a disappointment our friend who
couldn't really ever win a world
heavyweight title has won one well I
feel like Andy Murray suffers from that
a little bit yeah you know through his
success I mean Tim him and another
example good old Tim couldn't quite win
win Wimbledon we love him yeah you know
and that that sometimes the British
mentality we need to move more towards
educating young people that you know you
have to achieve you on your on your
cabinet in your office you have a school
board Eddie V Barry School Board boxing
skills it says one nil to Eddie you
obviously you beat him snooker skills
one nil to Barry he beats you at snooker
Instagram followers 62 Barry 1.2 million
Eddie Amazon book I love this Amazon
book reviews 33 Barry
1370 for Eddie hi well obviously your
daughter the name golf handicap uh
you're now beating him so actually
you're quite ahead now on the metric but
I'll tell you one very quick story about
my old man which the book is the one
right so I get asked to write a book
it's called Relentless it's about you
know my work ethic my love for the
business the sport all that kind of
stuff wrote it in three months with a
Ghostwriter during lockdown right he's
been writing his for nine or ten years
you know I won't want to embarrass him
but I made significantly more money for
my fee to write the book than he did but
what he said was what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take more money on
commission so I'm going to make more
money than you after the book was
written fantastic book took him six or
seven years to write the book it was I
must recommend he drove around the
country with books in the boot and was
knocking him out at events to try and
outsell me right I think I've done 60
000 he done eight thousand in Yen but
this is what I'm up against you know I
get the feeling though because you have
such a lovely relationship I've seen it
the first time and you're very similar
in many ways and he just wanted you to
be the best you could possibly be even
if that meant you were more successful
than him I don't think he really minded
that he just never wanted you to
shortchange yourself right he wanted you
to be the best competitive Beast that he
could possibly Empower you to be and he
wants me you know he wants to be a
graphic he wants to win and that's the
thing with business now you know we are
we he might say to me how'd you get on
it Dallas Cowboys you know how many
turned up to that Canelo fight you know
and he'll say well have you seen the
ratings for the darts smashed your box
in it's like that we're in the same
company you know but that's that but I'm
like this for my sons
he'll try and kill me yeah I mean but I
want nothing else I don't want them
giving me anything I want to give them
anything when I played table tennis with
my daughter who's 11 I want to beat her
so that when she finally beats me she
knows she beat me trying to beat her
that will mean so much more than if I
just let her win yeah that's exactly
what happens around my old man's house
on a Sunday
let just want to ask you quickly about
Conor bang because I interviewed him on
this this show he's one of your your
Fighters I gotta say I I ended that
interview really just not sure what to
believe but actually veering slightly I
felt in my gut that he might be telling
the truth that he has been the victim of
a miscarriage of Justice here over this
uh suggestive that he took illicit drugs
you believe in him why why are you so
convinced because I've known Connor Ben
since he was 18 19 years of age since he
came over from Australia on his own left
his mum and dad there to make a name for
himself in boxing the meticulous nature
of his preparation you know his love of
the sport
um you know his deep Faith all of the
things the way he trains with Tony Sims
the closeness of their relationship the
way that he was so insistent on
additional testing that he paid for
going into this fight
and the amount of times that I've sat
with this young man in my office and
watched him break down in tears yeah he
did it on the floor and and for me to
question him I didn't believe him a
certainly you know because you've been
criticized because you've always ripped
into other cheating because you know
what in in this instance and in life in
general guilty until proven innocent my
first reaction was I can't believe it he
would like he wouldn't do that do you
believe you'll be exonerated I do and I
believe you know he went through the
right procedure with the WBC involver
that's who did the test he was cleared
he was reinstated in the rankings
everyone said oh he needs to go through
a ucad in a British boxing border
control he turned around he went okay
I'll do that as well he spent hundreds
of thousands going through that process
and the result is imminent and I believe
him and I've had it's one year since the
test every day I mean I've had loads of
stick he's had Untold and if he's
cleared which I believe he will be I
hope that some people unders stand what
he went look at Kevin Spacey the actor
who today got found not guilty on all
these sex assault charges he's been
already convicted by the court of public
opinion on Twitter mercilessly called
the most horrendous things and today
he's come out an innocent man Twitter is
and social media generally it's an
unforgiving call that just prosecutes
people without seeing evidence and I
feel that a little bit about Conor
that'd be interesting to see what
happens on that before I let you go
how much are you worth me if you died
tomorrow
I don't know yes you do I don't know yes
you do anything no to the nearest table
I tell you what we're doing all right
but I'll work like I'm skinned every day
that's a good that's a good model and if
you were prime minister which many
people think you should be you couldn't
do them the worst job in the Tories have
done the last 10 years let's be honest
what's the first thing you do to fix
this country the first thing I would do
would be to increase participation in
sport for young Jew our young kids are
in a terrible terrible situation social
media disaster Twitter toxic you know
everybody that has ambition everybody
that has desire everybody that has a
strategy in their mind gets derailed by
negativity by people who can't do it all
you were saying I put a video out just
before we came over me and you right and
immediately in comes the abuse about
both of us right now we can handle it
we've got thick skins I think I say the
one quality I really have is great is
I've got an incredibly thick skin I just
watch this off to me most people I know
in the public eye find it really hard
but but you know we can say we've got a
thick skin which we have you have I have
but after waking up every morning it was
a great we said you know you wake up in
a great mood
what on Earth am I reading here what is
going on and that there's no point in
infiltrating yourself with negativity
Life's Too Short we can handle it kids
can't no that's the difference and
they've been bombarded with constant
negative stuff and the algorithms of
content which is ultimately designed to
feed the way they think yeah you see you
see girls who talking to each other
about self-harming next thing Tick Tock
is sending them loads of stuff total
it's feeding a horrible thing we and we
you know parents have to make sure that
you limit that time and we have to
educate the kids and I think the best
way to educate is through sport every
time you see a kid put down their fun I
agree and participate I agree with
energy with a smile on their face with a
desire to win and compete it's the
greatest thing to watch and whether it's
boxing which I'm a massive fan of or you
know the government need to make sure
that we keep the opportunities because
inner city schools just don't have a
sport they don't I went from a fee
paying prep school at 12 13 too
comprehensive and I went from playing
three hours of sport a day to nothing
once a week if someone can finally care
or a teacher just it's not good enough
this country has to do that I think
sport is the answer actually it's good
for well-being it's good for physical
the mental everything Eddie I could talk
to you all night and I felt your guns
earlier you did feel like a devil and in
fact you would say why are you not why
are you not competing I need I need your
I need your schedule thank you well you
may see my pin tweet on Twitter which is
Ronaldo telling me what great abs I've
got uh now he knows all about ABS Eddie
great to see you thank you come back
again I loved it I should do more I
really appreciate it and you're so right
about all of it thank you yes
I says that next he's the world's most
hated dictator so what's behind the
growing movement of commentators who
hate Ukraine that love Vladimir Putin
I'll debate with one of those next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
assistant
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook with
uncensitive Vladimir Putin is probably
one of the most hated leaders in the
world right now that's what happens when
you invade illegally a Sovereign Nation
that all your army distorted innocent
people but as well as opposing the West
Financial military backing for Ukraine a
substantial movement of digital
influences hold put in a bizarrely high
regard praising him as a peace-loving
leader who stands up his country Jackson
Hinkle a conservative commentator in
YouTube over 260 000 subscribers is a
prominent voice in this Pro Putin
Community recently tweeted Putin has got
on his side in his quest to defeat NATO
satanists so why is he saying all this
well let's ask him do what I mean now is
the Putin fan YouTuber Jackson England
the Russian British host of the
trigonometry podcast Constantine kissing
okay welcome to both of you Jackson I
don't get it uh Vladimir Putin invaded
illegally a democratic sovereign country
has rigged total Mayhem is killed
innocent women children's bomb maternity
hospitals uh he's been on a barbaric
Rampage why would you choose this moment
to Revere him
I would choose this moment because most
of what is said about Vladimir Putin in
the mainstream press by Talking Heads
like yourself is just factually not true
just like everything that people like
you said about covet uh the fact of the
matter is this war that everyone talks
about that so so-called started on
February 24 2022 actually began in 2014
after the U.S led a violent coup on the
Ukrainian government that was
democratically elected when people
specifically ethnic Russians in the
dombas decided that they didn't want a
U.S installed puppet government filled
with Nazis they vocalized their opinions
and for that they were met with violence
and aggression by the Ukrainian
government who slaughtered them for
eight years fifteen thousand people died
in this fighting while Putin tried to
achieve peace through the Minsk Accords
and the mints two Accords all of which
ended up being rejected by the Ukrainian
government at the behest of Germany in
the United States
Ukrainian government continue to push
forward despite the fact that Putin
wanted peace and they said that they
wanted to join NATO they said they
wanted to have nukes right on Russia's
border and because of that Putin stepped
in and said hey look we're going to stop
the Bloodshed we're going to stop the
NATO escalation we're going to stop the
risk of potentially this unfolding into
a full-fledged nuclear war and we're
going to do what needs to be done we're
going to liberate the ethnic Russians in
Ukraine we're going to denatify you
again and we're going to denoxify all
right I'm giving you a good chance to
answer that I've got to say a lot of
that I thought was a Crocker crap but
let me go to Constantine kiss it because
it said I find this attitude completely
mind-blowing there used to be a time
when Americans in particular certainly
conservative Americans when faced with a
choice between a democratic sovereign
country and a murderous Russian dictator
invading them they wouldn't even
hesitate to support the ukrainians in
this battle what has happened this term
people like this guy into Putin lovers
who just think he's a man of Peace well
he did say that Putin stepped into and
the Bloodshed which I thought is
interesting given what's been going in
Ukraine for the last year and a half but
actually there's a history I mean first
of all isolationism is a policy that has
had some support in America historically
in fact 1939 1940 there were people
marching up and down Times Square saying
Hitler hasn't done anything to us let's
have peace with Hitler so Jackson's
following in their footsteps there but
you were right in your introduction this
is a very online phenomenon and I was
just in several conservative states in
America West Virginia uh Utah you go
around as Ukraine flags on on most of
the houses there so this is quite a
fringe position but I think uh Jackson
actually alluded to some of the reasons
there is a growing movement of people
who feel that they've been liked to by
the mainstream media quite rightly by
the way particularly over things like
covet yeah and they've developed a sort
of teenage oppositional Defiance
disorder where they now think that the
truth is whatever is the opposite of
what the mainstream is saying and we've
just heard a very good representation of
that yeah I mean Jackson I
I don't remember you've lost our
connection with you unfortunately which
will immediately lead people on social
media to claim it's a conspiracy and
we've silenced him that's not the case
we actually as he saw his head froze in
mid-rant uh we could hear his voice now
he can't hear either I think so because
it is just keep talking until we get
Jackson back I don't know I mean I don't
know where this mindset takes him I
always say to to conservatives uh who
come up with this kind of stuff well
what did you feel about the invasion of
Kuwait by Saddam Hussein the first one
because they weren't part of NATO QA and
yet the Americans along with the British
raced to throw Saddam Hussein out of
then I get told well he didn't have
nuclear weapons what we thought he did
actually have weapons of mass
destruction
um that whole period but it didn't stop
us doing what was morally the right
thing to do and it's that weird moral
maze that they've all got themselves
into where they're now defending the
very person that historically
conservatives would have railed against
and a KGB Colonel of course you remember
that too and it's interesting because
one of the arguments people like Jackson
make it's a Pity we've lost them because
I'd love to have more of a debate but
one of the things they seem to think is
that this guy is a representation of the
Christian tradition which is interesting
because uh this is a man who's had
several children out of wedlock with his
mistress and by the way what's
interesting is the people like Jackson
often talk about how under Vladimir
Putin Russia has become this great
country and by the way Putin has
stabilized Russia there's no argument
about that but most of the Elites in
Russia have their children and their
wives in Europe This is interesting
isn't it because they claim that Russia
is this great place on the Vladimir
Putin yet all of those people place
their families outside which is uh tells
you a lot about what they actually think
about the country so uh we've got
Jackson back I think Jackson uh
genuinely the connection went down so
there's no conspiracy we weren't trying
to silence you you no I just find it odd
I mean for argument's sake when
I'm Hussein invaded Q8 did you feel that
he was a peace-loving guy that we should
be instinctively supporting or did you
agree with American conservatives then
that what should actually happen is
Desert Storm and General Schwarzkopf
should be leading the American charge to
repel him and if you felt the latter why
would you feel differently about someone
like Putin doing this in Ukraine
well I don't know if you know Pierce I'm
only 23 years old so I didn't have fully
fledged opinions on that at the time but
what I think is very interesting is for
all the Western officials that are so
outraged over what Putin is doing in
Ukraine why were they not outrage over
what NATO did to Yugoslavia or what NATO
did to Libya or what the United States
did in Iraq and Afghanistan or Syria the
United States drone operation program in
Africa had a 95 civilian death rate for
everyone to be so up in arms over Putin
liberating these ethnic Russians in
Ukraine from Nazis is just I have no
suggestion Jackson the trouble is some
of the stuff you said in your initial
response is historically defensible you
can argue from 2014 there's been this
issue there I get that that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to say but
when you say that Putin's only game here
is to go and Liberate the ukrainians
from Nazis you just sound completely
Bonkers Bonkers not say there aren't
some far-right people with Nazi
tendencies in Ukraine there are as there
are in many countries but the idea this
is a nazi-run country when the president
is Jewish never mind anything else it's
laughably ridiculous
well just because each Jewish doesn't
mean he's not seeking his azov Nazi
thugs on ethnic Russians in the Dom back
you think a Jewish president is going to
be actively promoting Nazism
the ones with swastika tattoos and
Hitler tattoos and Mario for example
here's one question one question what
I'll say is if you're so outraged over
the you know the the atrocities
allegedly of Putin in Ukraine and all
these ukrainians that have been killed
and you tweet about it non-stop why did
you not tweet once about the atrocities
that were perpetrated by the Ukrainian
government from 2014 to 2022 against
those ethnic Russians in the Dom bass
well yeah well I my family are actually
largely ethnic Russians in Ukraine uh
the idea that there's a significant body
of people in Ukraine who by virtue of
being ethnic Russians support what
Vladimir Putin is doing it's complete uh
hogwash frankly
um and the lots of other points that
have been met I mean you're right there
are some far-right elements in Ukraine
as there are in America there's of
Battalion the Jackson's referring to was
formed after Russia invaded in 2014. in
the same way that if Mexico invaded the
United States it'd probably be some
far-right people going out and fighting
there so uh he's got the the whole thing
backwards uh which is not surprising you
know what we could probably explore this
in more detail I mean will Jackson I've
got no desire to censor you to stop you
having your views you're entitled to
them I will challenge them uh We've run
out of time tonight but I think we
should do this again another time uh you
can have a platform here we can talk
about these things because a lot of
people seem to agree with you which I
find baffling but that's the reality so
thank you for joining Piers Morgan on
census tonight Constantine always good
to see you I'll send us up next tonight
Kevin Spacey with today found not guilty
of sexually assaulted four men putting
into years of legal action against the
actor did they know in the clear will he
be able to revive his Hollywood career
like say Johnny Depp has done and if not
why not well that's next
okay
[Music]
good evening I'm Peters Morgan I'm
censored in New York City tonight on
Piers Morgan uncensored in Kiev Ukraine
tonight on Piers Morgan on special
edition tonight a special edition
appears more than uncensored Martina
navratulations he's making me cry again
you believe you can win this war so are
you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around
these protesting just don't get it many
of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
I would call it beautiful do you think
we should have psychiatric assessments
oh I'd be there for three weeks did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read the book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
we're all about this where are they
where's their children
Max will agree to be interviewed for the
very first time I obviously wish I'd
never met him you're shaking in your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it
oh
[Music]
what does a woman make
[Laughter]
it let it roll a woman is given to the
man in marriage Andrew You're simply
wrong I've been a terrible liar that's
true I mean would you be prepared to say
that I've been a terrible liar are you
sorry you said that
no nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I see new clown Tommy
Fury so please go easy on me bro
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I have nothing to hire
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth if you had to come up against
a team and had a Russian player would
you shake that no chance no chance it's
life and death This is what password
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know
you don't drink never taken drugs you're
stinking Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
this is talk TV
thank you
welcome back to Facebook I'm joined by
my Super PAC the talk to me contributor
Esther crackers associate author Grace
Blakely and from New York The Spectators
associate editor Douglas Murray welcome
to all of you I want to start uh with
you Douglas Kevin Spacey a dramatic turn
of events today where Kevin Spacey was
found not guilty of all charges in the
sex assault case this despite being
already convicted by the inevitable
Court of public opinion on social media
for a year this is what he said when he
came out of court afterwards
I would like to say
that I'm enormously grateful to the jury
for having taken the time
to examine all of the evidence and all
of the facts
carefully
before they reach their decision
and I am humbled
by the outcome today
now what was interesting uh I thought
Douglas was
um the number of people I've heard on
the Airways commentators broadcasters
and so on saying You know despite this
it's going to be almost impossible for
Kevin Spacey to get his career back in
Hollywood to which my response
instinctively is why the guy's just been
found not guilty right have we got this
to me is the is the personification of
cancer culture where someone is found
innocent on all charges and yet there's
a kind of presumption that he can't
return to his previous career
well one thing appears is I mean you
said that this is a surprising verdict
it's not surprising at all Kevin
Spacey's been exonerated at each of the
trials he's been put through he's
exonerated in the U.S last year he was
exonerated today in London anyone who
followed the U.S trial of civil case of
Anthony rat knows that Anthony Rapp made
false allegations against Kevin Spacey
that were proved to be false in the U.S
court now if anyone followed closely the
incredibly uh weak appalling uh case
that the CPS brought against him in the
UK the the four um claimants had one of
the weakest cases I have ever seen
brought before a jury and nobody who
followed this case could possibly be
surprised that the jury came back saying
that Kevin Spacey was innocent he has
been repeatedly proven innocent in court
for six years now he has been put
through the most incredibly intense
um cancellation you could possibly
imagine six years of false allegations
against him and a destroyed career and
just remember before this he was one of
the most successful actors on the planet
the House of Cards was the most
successful Show on Netflix this shows
what happens when a society loses grip
of the idea of innocent until proven
guilty and decides always believe the
alleged Victim Because you know what
sometimes the alleged victim is a an
absolute provable liar and that has been
the case in the trials of Kevin Spacey
and I wish that our society would learn
something from it it's yeah listen Grace
it's a it's you know I look at Kevin
Spacey I see a guy life ruined he's got
no money left apparently who came out in
court he's got no career no one will
hire him everyone dropped him like a
sack of Spuds social media persecutes
him merciless leaking victim and so on
what does it say about our society that
this guy turns out to have been innocent
of all charges but is dead and buried in
terms of his career I don't know if it
says something about our society you
know these cases are complicated they're
always incredibly complicated because
they often boil down to he said he said
she said obviously it is incredibly
important to maintain this idea of
innocent and proven guilty until proven
guilty social media
discussed behind the scenes what you
know if people say he's not going to
work again what you know there's always
this idea of there are people who it's
an Open Secret that they do actually
yeah
I'm talking about specifically about the
court of public opinion fueled on social
media which is so merciless that it
makes people so damaged because I do
peers that that is what happens when you
put yourself into public eye you know
there is there are going to be people
who are going to want to take you down
and you know we have a legal system for
this reason it's to try and get to the
truth at the bottom of some of these
allegations to make sure that people are
um that these things legally at least do
abide by the principle of innocent until
proven guilty there's nothing you can do
short of literally censoring free speech
to stop public figures from being
attacked well actually what you can do
Esther I mean I saw that on the Hugh
Edwards story for example when a lot of
other BBC male presenters started being
inaccurately accused of being that
person you know Jeremy Vine was one of
the people who took legal action against
one of these people and actually did
make the person pay a thousand pounds to
a charity maybe public figures just do
need to start suing people on social
media on a regular basis to make them
realize you can't just say everything
you want and you feel like it when
someone's facing a trial it could be the
end of their entire careers well that's
certainly part of it but I think two
things need to be done here one if if a
claim meant in a case like this is has
proven proven to be a liar they need to
be prosecuted we really need to tighten
the laws on these things because these
acutely affects
if you say if it's proven because it's
difficult because then you don't want to
disincentivate thank you
social media companies do not abide by
the same regulations that say the print
media do or broadcast media do and it's
a massive
problems
I think it's insane they are Publishers
and they should be treated
I need to make a point about this
because actually this isn't just about
social media it's also about the media
the media went huge internationally when
Anthony Rapp made his initial provably
false allegation about Kevin Spacey the
international media around the world
went huge on that allegation it was only
an allegation now of course social media
then whipped it along and made it even
worse and made his career even more in
tatters but if you look at the fact how
many viewers know that that Kevin Spacey
was exonerated last year in the U.S
courts on the Anthony rap charges though
this is a fault of the media as well the
media very often whip along the initial
claims and do not cover the subsequent
judicial findings and that is a major
problem of the media not just of social
yeah I think that's actually it's legit
because a lot of the media doesn't cover
things that they consider to be boring
yeah and that's like a matter
well I mean we can blame the media but I
think the bigger the bigger conversation
is culture right just for every person
that is saying that Kevin Spacey was
guilty there needs to be 10 people
saying wait until he has been proven
guilty we don't see that on social media
and the reason for it is because we are
so averse to seeing someone being
accused of sexual assault not fraud or
other other crimes that they are
automatically assumed to be guilty for
every person that said Kevin Spacey was
guilty there should have been 10 people
saying wait until he's been pleaded
guilty that's the problem I had one
other thing yeah one other thing if I
may which is the problem of this is It's
the social media thing is you have
rapacious hordes of people who want to
demonstrate their their ostentatious
horror and apparent virtue by standing
as being opponents of the claim but you
do not find rampatious hordes of people
going around social media trying to show
that people are innocent yeah we only
have nothing it is the Salem Witch
Trials it is and it's McCarthy I and
it's horrible and is out of control and
as more and more people go on to social
media it just gets worse and worse and I
think something has to give these tech
companies have to be held more
accountable for what they allow to be
published on their platforms
I don't actually know what stats you
took on this as you pay so can you
remind me but when um it's like Donald
Trump was banned from Twitter yeah what
was your view on I don't think he should
have been well I mean where are we
supposed to draw the line here you know
I don't think we should be banning any
president you're not giving you know
unlimited power but I don't think you
should be banished I actually don't
think that let me explain most of these
peopleship I didn't think I should have
that much power my argument was if
you're going to allow the Ayatollah of
Iran and the Taliban of Vladimir Putin
to have Twitter accounts you can't
remove it but who decides uh you know
exactly if someone says
I personally don't think Elon Musk
private billionaire who's you know a
weird guy she's given that much power
pay 44 but then you can do it
really have you you can do what you like
very quick say what you like if you have
enough money right did that to wind you
up and it worked uh Esther Mick Jagger
so Mick Jagger's 80 years old today
quick reaction the the the can I call
him Krusty anyway happy birthday happy
birthday Mick Jagger please stop having
kids Douglas Murray meet Jack is the
same age as Joe Biden I mean is there
not evidence right there that Joe
Biden's problem is not his age it's
everything else
all I can say is that if Mick Jagger
were running for president I'd back him
oh well Mick Jagger come on he's a
that's the problem I'm not asking you
have you you have to be worried about it
I mean no what no happy birthday to him
but happy birthday we can all can't we
all Embrace Mick Jagger 80 the great is
opportunity in the world right give up
on the list of blue pill incredible no
he doesn't he doesn't give anything
credible energy great role model loves
to make Jagger the greatest front man in
the history of rock music Happy Birthday
Mick keep on rocking keep giving us
satisfaction that's it for me thank you
Douglas thank you Grace thank you Esther
whatever you're up to tonight keep it
like Mick Jagger uncensored
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Morgan uncensored in New York City
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored in
Kiev Ukraine tonight on Piers Morgan I'm
a special edition from cancer tonight a
special edition appears more than
uncensored Martinez making me cry again
do you believe you can win this winter
are you gonna run again I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy yes I
feel betrayed they're trying to force
you out yes not only the coach but the
other two or three guys there around
well these protesting just don't get it
many of them don't it's not slightly
patronizing
I would call it you know
look at the window do you think we
should have psychiatric assessments
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read a
book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
[Music]
why isn't someone
else to win the castle it's from that
much cushier jail that Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him you're shaking your
prime minister
party can certainly win the next
election can we yes
this is the royalty question is did he
say yes I have taken drugs and they've
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore